[Musica]
grazie grazie
sono veramente onorato orgoglioso di
essere qui questa sera ringrazio te ed
ex ferrara per avermi chiamato in fondo
per raccontare la mia storia la mia
esperienza personale la mia leggenda
personale su questa terra dei primi i
miei 31 anni quindi spero di non
annoiarvi e spero che in fondo possiate
vedere in questa mia storia delle tinte
universali e spero che alla fine di
questa conversazione posata intravedere
anche una diversa prospettiva del vostro
futuro delle vostre ambizioni che avete
nei confronti e della vostra vita
ci sono due protagonisti in questa
nostra conversazione una è la nostra
bellissima ferrara di cui vado molto
orgoglioso io sono nato afferrare sono
ferrarese ho vissuto a ferrara fino a 18
anni e il secondo protagonista forse il
primo protagonista e quel bambino che ci
guarda e che mi guarda ogni sera da
circa e 31 anni
io sono stefano moroni sono soprattutto
un attore ma nel corso del tempo sono
anche diventato scrittore e produttore
cinematografico presento da 10 anni a
giffoni film festival dal 2019 sono
anche diventato commissario per il
ministero italiano come esperto del
cinema uno dei quindici esperti del
cinema che collabora col mibac direzione
generale per il cinema ma questa sera
voglio presentarmi come quello che in
realtà sono un imprenditore della
creatività come ho trasformato la mia
creatività in impresa la mia creatività
in mestiere e il lavoro non poteva
essere altrimenti credo perché sono di
ferrara perché sono ferrarese a ferrara
nasce tra 400 e il 500 la commedia
dell'arte tra ferrara mantova venezia
padova ufficialmente a padova nel 1545
che cos'è la commedia dell'arte una
corrente da trarre italianissima famosa
nel mondo avrà il successo totale nel
seicento ma ci dice soprattutto una cosa
che commedianti gli attori registi
diventano per la prima volta mestieranti
professionisti sono pagati per il loro
lavoro siamo noi italiani nel mondo che
diamo la professionalità al mondo della
creatività in questo caso del teatro
ferrara
ludovico ariosto ecco che un uomo con un
tasso di creatività sublime il geniale
immagina ha una visione un uomo il
cavaliere sulla groppa di un cavallo
alato che lo chiamo ipo grifo e volla
sulla luna a ricercare il senno
dell'umanità perduto per cercare di
riportarlo sulla terra ecco che la
creatività diventa genio diventa
letteratura diventa poesia ma arriviamo
anche al novecento sto ovviamente
sintetizzando beh a ferrara nasce la
pittura metafisica giorgio de chirico ma
il novecento è l'arte l'arte
cinematografica afferrare prima nel
mondo
michelangelo antonioni florestano
vancini folco quilici giorgio bassani
adriana benetti viva del neorealismo
italiano sandro simeoni dimenticato il
primo grande pittore per il cinema
famoso nel mondo era nato a migliarino
provincia di ferrara nasce un bambino
nel 1925 qui a pochi passi in provincia
vigarano mainarda che è molto bravo con
le mani
eclettico e geniale e a volte scappa da
casa con la creta l'argilla del fiume po
costruisce i primi mostri e le prime
paperelle la madre disperato dio che
figlio sta venendo su lo chiama tu devi
studiare devi fare il geometra questo
bambino diventerà anche geometra ma
sentiva dentro che era un po diverso
dalla media nazionale se certamente il
suo paese quindi studia le belle arti di
bologna inizia a lavorare nel cinema di
roma crea gli effetti speciali all'epoca
erano i trucchi lui inventa di effetti
speciali e rom pioniere è un genio del
novecento poi viene chiamato in america
nel 75 76 e rimane sei anni fa king kong
alien ed et i vince tre oscar si
chiamava carlo rambaldi era nato a
vigarano mainarda
tutti questi straordinari personaggio
fin da bambino li conoscevo e quindi ero
certamente un bambino molto creativo ma
consapevole della memoria del passato e
delle radici della nostra città del
nostro territorio
forse ero ancora più creativo quindi
qual era il mio sogno
quando ero un bambino io sono quel
bambino se capitolo due o tre anni
volgia i soldi in mano qualche mille
lire
io ve lo dico sinceramente volevo fare
l'attore
io nel diario segreto quando avevo 5
anni scrivevo voglio fare l'attore come
bud spencer e terence hill
mia madre era abbastanza disperata
perché un bambino come far l'attore sei
anni e un po strano e poi siamo nel 1995
abbastanza preso di mira gli vengo da
tresigallo provincia di ferrara
i coetanei il pagliaccio e buffon e il
fallito ma chi ti credi di essere ero
abbastanza preso di mira e questo è
avvenuto da sei anni ai 18 anni non me
n'è mai fregato niente anzi avevo un
idea molto precisa dell'attore volevo
studiare al centro sperimentale di
cinematografia di roma la scuola
nazionale del cinema
la più antica del mondo dove su 1.200 ne
prendevano 8 e io ho investito tutta la
mia vita da sei anni 18 anni per
arrivare ai provini del centro
sperimentale ho fatto di tutto tutto
quello che la mia città offriva musica
pianoforte ho sempre sospettato che un
attore dovesse sapere cosa fosse il
senso del ritmo della melodia
dell'armonia fatto otto anni di
pianoforti di cui 5 al conservatorio ho
fatto ovviamente laboratori di teatro il
corsera per gli adulti c'erano i
sessantenni settantenni e ottantenni
sono anch'io ho iniziato a 12 anni
ho fatto anche vela perché la vera ma
insegnato in fondo che non puoi cambiare
la direzione del vento ma sfruttando il
vento tu puoi trovare la tua direzione
questa cosa mi è servita particolarmente
arrivo al liceo quell'anno
incredibilmente nasce il liceo socio
psico pedagogico che esisteva già di ciò
carducci indirizzo musica e spettacolo
mia madre ennesima volta disperata no
uno bravo commenta deve fare l'ariosto
liceo più il fighetto posso dire così
della nostra città più importante mio
fratello ha fatto anche l'ha visto io
volevo fare invece il carducci
anche perché da quando avevo 12 anni
iniziava a mettere in banca i soldi che
ho prendevano i compleanni nelle feste e
nelle pasque e anche per le borse di
studio a 12 anni
l'avis di tresigallo dava 155 euro a
coloro che uscivano con ottimo ero bravo
insomma studiavo continua a studiare i
miei primi 155 euro messi in banca per
quando andrò a roma nel madre voleva
chiamare lo psicologo l'esorcista non lo
so però entro a carducci quell'anno era
il primo anno forse sembravano una
specie di amici saranno famosi quindi
anche lì non ho trovato dei coetanei
molto sensibili ai miei sogni arrivo a
18 anni e finalmente dopo 12 anni di
investimento sulla mia esistenza dal
punto di vista creativo saluto capre e
cavoli
vado a roma tentò la messina centro
sperimentale di cinematografia di come
funziona niente su 1.200 prima ne
passano 600 quei 600 diventano 560 poi
diventano 42 40 fanno il seminario
propedeutico del mese di novembre per un
mese e quel 40 diventano 8 8 maschi e 8
femmine e la faccio breve dicembre 2008
tra quegli otto ragazzi italiani
selezionati da giancarlo giannini c'è
anche il mio nome
stefano muroni inizio tre anni
straordinari a roma faccio tre anni con
giancarlo giannini con bertolucci con
pupi avati con i fratelli italiani
facciamo una lezione straordinaria con
woody allen è stata una grandissima
esperienza è uno degli otto eletti a
livello nazionale questi sentire i
presuntivo e red carpet r1 porta a porta
finisco il centro sperimentale mi
diploma giancarlo giannini ed ennio
morricone
finisco centro sperimentale e dopo il
diploma o una grande opportunità nessuno
si chiama nessuno mi contatta e nessuno
mi cerchi il telefono squilla e non solo
a me ma al 95 per cento dei ragazzi che
erano in classe con me
passano sei mesi da roma e tutti gli
amici lasciano la città romana che torna
reggio calabria chi torna ad ortona in
abruzzo che a belluno che a firenze io
rimango solo e per qualche giorno
scricchiolato detto avevano ragione i
nemici ea nanna la triennale
metti la testa a posto pensa piano b da
quel bambino continua a parlarne ogni
sera che tanto sognava di fare questo
mestiere mento stefano fai di tutto per
realizzare messo ogni te ne prego allora
il sentiva mente un iniziato a scrivere
il mio primo cortometraggio si chiama 30
e lode
l'ho scritto ho cercato i finanziamenti
1.500 euro lo prodotto l'ho interpretato
chiamo cento festival mi rispondono in
quattro e in uno vinciamo se rompiamo
festival di terni menzione speciale
dopo trenta e lode nessuno mi chiama
benissimo
faccio un mediometraggio di 20 minuti si
chiama tommaso parla dell'eutanasia lo
scrivo cerco i finanziamenti 8 mila euro
lo producono interpreto recito con
monica guerritore giulio brogi richiami
cento festival 10 mi rispondono quei
quattro più altri 6 e trionfi amo al
festival del corto di roma vinco il
colosseo d'argento bravo complimenti
dopo questo mediometraggio nessuno mi
chiama allora tenta l'impossibile
l'inverosimile facciamo un film 20 29
maggio 2012 terremoto dell'emilia 5.9 io
ora tresigallo e l'ho sentito tutto
passano sei mesi e gli italiani lo
dimenticano i mass media lo dimentico
nel sottoscritto lo dimentica allora
penso di incidere su pellicola per
sempre quello che era avvenuto per fare
memoria di quello che siamo stati dei
nostri morti per quelli che c'erano
ancora ma soprattutto per coloro che
sarebbero arrivati dopo di noi
scrivo la sceneggiatura cerchi
finanziamenti secondo me con 33mila euro
potevamo fare grandi cose e inizia un
lavoro estenuante di un anno e mezzo nel
mio territorio per cercare questi soldi
faccio 47 incontri fare un incontro non
è facile di meno risponde telefoni
l'imprenditore non c'è non c'è la banca
per un incontro difficile non fatti 47
un anno e mezzo e ho beccato 47 no no il
tuo progetto non ci interessano la gente
vuole ridere 9 essere in qualcos'altro
erano sui tuoi sogni sotto
professionalità sul tuo progetto sulla
tua vita
tornavo a casa mia madre mi diceva
stefano
sei stanco non ama si stancano loro ti
invito alla prima e ti regalo il
biglietto in prima fila 48esimo incontro
si è interessante tiro 3 mila euro porca
miseria mai all incredibile faccio a tre
incontri altri nobel così altri nove
così alla fine trovo 33mila euro vado a
roma tutti infine tatum onestamente
trovato 33mila euro possiamo fare fin
sul terremoto delle miglia produttore
romano mi chiamo muroni di cognome a
muro te serve almeno un milione e mezzo
con 33mila euro non c'era ma anche un
videoclip e torno a casa e ho pensato
stefano i sogni hanno dei limiti
basta bravo il corto prove
mediometraggio non lo sai ritorna a
parlarmi quel bambino e mi dice stefano
fregatene fallo fallo se te lo senti
fallo come viene viene
non aveva un milione e mezzo ma 33 mila
euro non avevamo due mesi e mezzo di
girare per girare ma nove giorni alla
fine in un film bellissimo di 65 minuti
e viene presentato in anteprima mondiale
a bruxelles
pago il biglietto i miei genitori che
sono in prima fila arriva al giffoni
film festival va alla festa del cinema
di roma come evento speciale vinciamo
una segnalazione speciale ai nastri
d'argento entriamo in selezione david di
donatello ma il miracolo dei miracoli
dopo crotte educatamente le scatole di
un'azienda che si chiama sky sky lo
acquista maggio giugno 2017 cinque anni
dal sisma su sky cinema 1 sky cinema
cult sky cinema 24 gli italiani hanno
visto la notte non fa più paura il film
sul terremoto dell'emilia che ho scritto
prodotto interpretato da lì arriva al
successo mi chiamare uno rai due rai tre
e rai movie rai più muniti il nuovo
attore che produce anche le proprie
opere che che scrive che parla della
memoria del presente
e allora li capisco che forse non sono
solo un attore come c'era scritto nel
diploma di recitazione forse posso
essere un imprenditore delle mie storie
un imprenditore della mia creatività un
agente di me stesso un produttore
cinematografico e quindi presento a
venezia nello stesso anno 2017 la
società di produzione controluce
produzione con mia moglie valeria luzi
che a proposito di sogni è la donna dei
miei sogni e negli ultimi tre anni
abbiamo realizzato tre documentari per
le 22 ott serie principio pd e treccani
e il nostro ultimo film il film su don
giovanni minzoni parroco ucciso
1923 d'argenta film girato nel basso
ferrarese e anche questo film va la
festa del cinema di roma e dopo aver
rotto educatamente le scatole a sky ho
rotto educatamente le scatole alla rai e
la rai
miracolosamente l'ha acquistato e quindi
tre mesi fa eravamo in prima serata su
rai storia e andrà anche su 5 su rai3 e
spero in qualsiasi canale della rai io
vivo di questo era qualche anno vivo
grazie alla mia creatività
visto che mancano due minuti posso
raccontarvi cosa mi ha insegnato questa
storia
questa favola di provincia che tutta
vera primo punto è possibile
io non ho dimenticato quando era bambino
mi dicevano ma figurati se uno di
tresigallo può andare a roma a fare
l'attore
noi non siamo il paese da cui proveniamo
noi siamo i sogni che abbiamo nella
testa
secondo punto non è sempre vero che se
il mercato non ti dà un valore significa
che tu non abbia un valore non è così
spesso il mercato è distratto spesso il
mercato non capisce veri talenti non
capisce veri pionieri ci vuole tanto
tempo
terzo punto quando sono uscito dalla
scuola in fondo la scuola di cinema e mi
ha insegnato ora e devi competere con il
mercato a volte forse uno può anche
creare il proprio mercato e cercare di
competere con un mercato ufficiale
ultimo punto è più importante
cercate di avere sempre un grande sogno
perché nelle notti romane che ero
rimasto da solo se non c'era un solo
kimi trainava del suo futuro ero
spacciato
se non avesse avuto un grande sogno che
47 nome avrebbero ucciso e mi avrebbero
ammazzato credete fortemente al potere
creativo dei sogni perché spesso il
potere creativo regioni vi porta ad una
grande visione e quindi come diceva
paolo quello nel romanzo l'alchimista se
uno un sogno forte ma deve essere
veramente forte tutte le forze
dell'universo co spireranno affinché tu
possa realizzare quel sogno può sembrare
una frase fatta a me è successo io ero
solo come un cane ma ascoltavo
l'universo e sono sicuro che l'universo
mi ascoltava e ci ho creduto da solo
credeva in me stesso nessuno ci credeva
ma il piano piano ci hanno creduto tutti
quindi credete fortemente
i sogni non ascoltate nessuno credete
nelle vostre visioni che l'uomo che
crede nei sogni e le proprie visioni un
uomo psicologicamente scientificamente
più felice e più sereno spiritualmente
quindi grazie stato un privilegio serie
qui buonanotte fate dei sogni veramente
con tutto il cuore grazie di cuore
[Applauso]